watching this do not marry such woman
ever in your life
I used to struggle reading the Quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app I never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for IOS
and Android and build your habit with
the Quran right now
I came across a video on Instagram
explore page and I watched this and I
was thinking what could possibly
possibly possibly go wrong about a
non-muslim woman who if I'm not mistake
my wife said she dresses you know a
certain times inappropriately Muslim
standards you know making food for a
husband what could possibly ever go
wrong well when feminists are involved a
lot of things go wrong because you can
never do anything right here is the
video watch it for yourself and find out
how this non-muslim woman who dresses up
you know maybe in an inappropriate way
according to our Muslim stands because
I'm making this point for a reason it's
not mainly per se about why she's
dressed it's not about why she dressed
there is a reason behind her mentioning
this which you're going to find out
right after this video inshallah Let's
just watch it for ourselves who would
have ever thought packing my husband's
controversial I've been getting so many
comments talking about how why can't he
pack his own lunch he's such a baby why
are you doing this for him this is so
embarrassing for you no he deserves a
hot lunch he deserves a good meal he
goes to work every day and works for our
family I pack his lunch because he
deserves it just like our family
deserves to be taken care of too I do
this because we're a team
so guys I mean you can't make this stuff
up you cannot make this stuff up she is
a non-muslim woman making food for her
husband and she loves every damn second
of it but no no no
how dare you have you seen the comment
section guys read the comment section
it's flipping crazy crazy these people
are flipping tapped in the head crackers
I'm gonna start calling feminist
crackers they are crackheads and they're
not even smoking crap and it's a
crackhead I'm smoking crack you know but
you are a cracker on a different level I
don't know what the hell you've been
smoking it's unbelievable that people
like can he not make his own food you
know is he a boy is he a child you know
or if you wasn't there and I'm thinking
to myself what on Earth are you on about
there is a woman who's finally happy
content pleasing her husband and making
him watch everything he wants and he
orders he says I want this today good on
him and good on you dear sister the
reason if you're watching this I'm
mentioning your clothing style or you
know your modesty is for a reason please
don't get me wrong I'm going to mention
why how many more Muslim women are out
there who wear the liquor who were the
jilbab who were the Abaya who
practically who reads Quran who
memorized the Quran you know dude
there's so many Buddhism
but is affected by feminism to such a
level that if she was to tell her
friends she cooks for her husband or if
she was to tell her friends I am not
allowed to go out yes because my husband
said so yes he said I would not like you
to go out today and guess what I would
not like you to wear this lipstick I
would not like to dress up in that
manner oh no no no no no no now it's
abuse it's counted as abuse you cannot
dare to say that let me tell you
something young men who are watching
this do not marry such woman ever in
your life this is a non-muslim woman
it's a non-muslim woman who dresses up
inappropriately who some sisters will
look and be like look how she's dressed
let me tell you something we know
alhamdulillah the state is of a Muslim
and we know that that's a different
story but they would look at this woman
and be like let me just say some of you
sisters some of you sisters not all some
of you sisters cannot be the toenail in
that woman's feet yes and I'm not
talking about Islam in this thing for a
side for a second just look at Woman to
Woman let me tell you something based on
that how she treats her husband and what
she does you cannot even be the toenail
on her feet I'm going to be very blunt
and honest today we are dealing with
absolute Maniacs some brothers for the
red pill which will come and discuss
this in different topics but today's
topic is about feminism this is the
point the prophet remember the peaceful
upon him said if a man if a woman prays
a daily profile prayers fast in Ramadan
gives him thus her Duty basic things and
her husband is pleased with her she can
enter Jannah through any of the doors of
Jannah just imagine that basic stuff not
this woman praying qayam and Quran
she does the basics of the Basin and her
husband is pleased with her she can
enter Jannah from any door and the
processarily another narration said a
woman who dies and her husband is
pleased with her she will enter paradise
and enter General
and those women who got their Chastity
and who are obedient yes sister and
feminist obedient to the husbands now
which husband am I talking about it's
not the husband that hits you beats you
talk rubbish to you insults you hits you
cheats on you doesn't provide for you an
absolute waste man no we're not talking
about that kind of a man we are talking
about a good man a good man so much said
that if I was to tell anyone to
prostrate to anybody if it was allowed
it would be the wife to the husband why
because the duties the man has to do put
in his life at risk providing protecting
and all that kind of stuff we're talking
of a good man the point I'm trying to
see is the following guys this disease
of feminism has crept into every single
damn household I speak to Brothers Left
Right Center I just ask questions and
wallahi this has creeped in to the best
of the best of women to the best deal
it's nobody's free for me nobody one bit
or another has affected us well lie it
is so so sad that a woman who wants to
come for a husband and imagine this he
is going and working like this guy isn't
working she's saying that my husband
works and she's the housewife she's
providing how could anyone in their mind
have a problem with that just imagine
for a second imagine for a second if a
man if the rose were reversed and the
brothers the men were attacking the guy
for doing something for her for his wife
what if it may be working why did you
need to work for her because she'll do
it on herself why don't you go at work
why did she provide why did she pay
electric gas bill tax Insurance rent
electric uh council tax you name it
let's go goes on why doesn't she do it
there would be chaos do you see the
double standards and I've said this
before on the British show and I will
say it again haven't you guys ever seen
Usman ever start a petition ever make
this phenomenon and talk about the fact
that when we come home have we ever
complained and said why don't our wives
help us with our work will we come from
work whatever maybe you're doing
accountancy or a solicitor bricklayer
whatever it may be why don't you come
and help me with my work ever ever No we
don't we don't complain we do not
complain we accept responsibility
wholeheartedly and we say that's our
duty and we do it but when it comes to
females and certain feminists not all of
them you see this disgusting attitude so
much so that this could have ruined that
woman's Life alhamdulillah by giving her
doubts oh I guess should no she gave you
guys the middle finger should I say she
gave you guys the middle finger said
Chris carrying on cooking for her
husband and I would say may Allah guide
them to Islam because best believe she
will be a damn good role model and you
know what she's a damn good role model
of how to be a wife to all the Muslim
sisters who are affected by feminism oh
watch her go learn from the Quran woman
the other woman who dress it
inappropriately you know go learn a few
things from this woman that if she was
walking down the road a lot of sisters
in hijab and the kabulary look how she's
dressed darling sister she is way better
than being a housewife than you could
ever be my dear sister with your
feminism so I just want to give a toast
that's all I have to say and to hell
with feminism red pill green pill
whatever it may be man-made Woman made
those we have Islam the Quran and the
Sunnah my dear sisters and brothers
abide by that stop looking for Solutions
outside till next time